hello again the government is launching
its new 2
billion pound kickstart scheme which
aims to create thousands of jobs
for unemployed young people joining us
to discuss it is the work and pension
secretary there's coffee hello to you
good morning nice to see you do you like
our new studios
lovely it's rather fabulous isn't it
nice and cool um
talk to me about the number of under 25s
on universal credit it's nearly double
during lockdown
yes and that's no surprise kay we know
we've been through quite a situation
where
uh unprecedented changes have happened
in our economic
outlook and that's one of the reasons
why we knew early on
that we needed to make sure we had
something where we could help in
particular
young people uh try and get their first
foot on the ladder
into the world of work and so this is a
really comprehensive program
right across the country there's no cap
on the number of places
but we do believe that we want employers
to come forward today
with the launch they can go online we
really want to get our first
kickstarters underway in november how
are you going to pay for it richie's
still not must be pulling his hair out
as it is
well i'm conscious that the chancellor
is balancing a number of different
activities
right across whether the extra support
that we've given to the nhs
also about young people in schools but
it is important that we want to try and
get the economy going again we think
this is a good way it's beneficial for
businesses
it's also very beneficial for young
people so there's that mutual benefit
that we believe
is certainly going to be worth the
investment yeah so you want to get
people back to work but looking at the
figures
uh yesterday from tfl they were saying
uh they were down
72 yesterday on the same time last year
the prime minister wants people to go
back to work people don't want to go
back to work
well we are seeing improving trends
across the country of course the schools
starting to reopen this week
many of them in a phased way a lot of
working parents will have the
opportunity much more readily
to go back to work if they want but it's
important that employers employees have
that conversation
it's not appreciate tfl is uh
the heart of the capital but there are
elements where right across the country
we know that people are including dwp
799 of our 804 sites are open
we've got more than half of people back
in the office but that's about the
maximum
capacity we can probably absorb without
taking on new buildings
so every employer is going through this
challenge so do you think half and half
is about right well
i think if we can try and uh keep it
going but i'm conscious that we do need
to make sure
we have covered safe environments for
people to work
and that will continue because this
virus has not gone away
of course we're doing a lot more and
better treatments for people
understanding that but it's still we've
still got a long distance to go what's
wrong with people
working from home if they are as equally
as productive hasn't
this virus shown us a new way of working
i think it's shown different ways that
people can work
i'm not going to particularly try and
interfere between an employee
and an employer on exactly how they will
do their job your department what do you
do with your well as i say we've just
got about more than half of people back
into
our offices right across the country
because a lot of what we do is frontline
face to face with different
organizations
but you know my experience in industry
people can work in different ways
but often you'll find kay i think that
when people start to change teams and
similar
a lot of the existing relationships
start have to be recreated
and so there'll be interesting
challenges for employers to decide what
are we missing out
on by not being at work with our
colleagues because we can't have that
water cooler moment because we have to
be
social distance like we are well indeed
and perhaps other aspects of social
media have replaced that or other ways
that people can do it
but this is uh obviously a decision for
employees employers but there is that
wider knock-on effect
we know that for example in their
capital there are a number of different
services which rely on people being here
in greater numbers and that's why we've
seen organizations make decisions not to
fully reopen
uh whether that's uh food outlets or
similar
but this is uh an unravelling situation
and it's uh we
need to want and want employers to be
agile but that's another reason why we
also recognize that they need some a
boost and i believe kickstart will help
give them that boost with effectively
six months of uh
employment which they can help a young
person but also help them as a business
you want kids back at school as well do
we know at this stage how many went back
yesterday
i'm not aware that statistics are out
yet i've got the feeling we probably
won't know till next week
um the in terms of uh it's quite normal
to see phased returns at the beginning
of an academic year
okay let me ask you about one of your
colleagues um
gavin williams and who's the education
secretary of course uh the guardian
reporting
that he was offered evidence that his
exam algorithm was flawed
two weeks before results were published
what do you think should he continue in
his job
absolutely i mean gavin was up before
parliament yesterday giving a statement
say he was scrutinized there
we know that off koala in front of the
select committee today
and i don't think it's news that um
gavin uh had
and uh the department of education had
looked at the algorithm
and of course had given them
reassurances uh but you know
gavin really is the best person to give
an account of what happened
um but i'm confident that he's right he
has responded
and parliament's had its chance to
scrutinize him yesterday why are you so
confident in him in his job given that
you know he he said that the algorithm
was fine even though we saw what
happened
in scotland and in wales he also said
that kids didn't need to wear face masks
and now they do
is it because he's not good enough at
his job or is it because it is
a movable feast and we literally don't
know where this which direction this
virus is going to take us
i think on things like face coverings uh
where the government's introduced
guidance is in places where there are
localized lockdowns so it's not
surprising that we have tailored
advice uh in different parts of the
country depending
on the local health situation so this
really is an agile situation
i am confident of coursing in gavin as
say parliament's had their chance to
fully scrutinize him yesterday and i'm
sure there'll be future opportunities
there's a big mistake though wasn't it
the algorithm thing it was a big mistake
i think that uh all the uh nations in
the uk
took this approach on algorithm
initially uh with different regulators
and we've seen uh what's happening
consequence but generally is for gavin
and i have absolutely full confidence in
gavin taking this forward
i'm guessing we wouldn't use it again
though i think that uh there are all
sorts of ways that algorithms get used
in daily life
but you know offcourse already consulted
on proposals for next year they need to
consider them
but the most important thing is making
sure schools are fully reopened
and i'm really pleased how many schools
have taken on
uh the opportunity but with a phased
approach which is the right approach
um you know we all make mistakes um i
know you to be a compassionate woman i
just wanted you to
talk to me briefly about mercy
bergumer and for our viewers mercy was
a woman who died of starvation in
scotland
her little baby was found crying next to
her you were asked
about it at the time you didn't want to
talk about it she was an asylum seeker
having reflected on it what would you
want to say about it okay i haven't
actually been asked about this lady
before so i don't know where that's come
from
um but um you know who i'm talking about
i think i know the situation and it's a
lady with uh
immigration status that may have changed
uh this really is a matter of the home
office to decide
uh what the immigration status is for
each individual
um i'm conscious that people can also
apply
uh for changes to the home office if
they are
uh struggling with aspects of that and
uh the home office
can make that change so they can get
access to public funds
i'm afraid i don't know the individual
details of this labor done
as i said i know you as a compassionate
woman this woman starred to death with
her baby next to her
well i don't know the exact ins and outs
i know it happened
in glasgow fairly recently um but really
the home office is the person who
decides on whether
what sort of society are we when a woman
starves to death
what i'm trying to say kay is that when
people are in
very difficult situations like that and
they're looking for help from the
government there are ways they can
access that help
but i don't know the individual case i'm
giving you the opportunity to be
compassionate about
you know okay i've just said people can
you know enough to know that this woman
died
and her starving baby was found next to
her and as i've said kay
when people are in very difficult
situations there are ways that the
government can help
but it may need an application from them
to say i need some help in this way
so i don't know the exact in there but
the government
has been helping millions of people
across the country people without
recourse to public funds
can apply to the government to get a
change in their status so they can get
support
but that takes them through a home
office route and then organizations like
dwp
can help okay you said of course it was
in glasgow staying in scotland uh nicola
sturgeon
announcing yesterday a draft bill for a
new scottish independence referendum
do you think that boris johnson will
allow that to happen well i think
this is the first i've heard of it and
i'm just somewhat surprised
last week we saw that scotland has a
record deficit
uh the union bonus is about two thousand
pounds per person in scotland
i really struggle to understand why this
is the right time to be thinking about
independence referendum
we just huge economic recovery ahead of
us and as a consequence i'm just
surprised that this is seen as the top
priority right now
what you will have heard of uh is uh the
new lineup for strictly i bet you're a
fan of strictly aren't you
i like a bit strictly i bet you do what
do you make of
nicola adams dancing as the first
same-sex couple
well i think it's a new adventure for
the bbc um
they're used to breaking new ground uh
on on the dance floor
uh it'll be interesting to see who leads
and who doesn't yeah because you're not
in favor of same-sex marriage are you
well i
took the view at the time and i i'd
still hold to that i have a strong faith
background about what is a legal
partnership and what is marriage
um but that's not a question for today
i'm a great believer in living let live
but i'll as i say i'll be interested to
see who will you vote for nicholas i've
got the feeling that nicola adams may
well take the lead
will you vote for her um i'll see who
the contestants are there are a great
number of there
i'm quite a fan of caroline quentin as
well who is it
would you like to take part no okay on
that note it's good to see
you stay there for just a second i
appreciate you taking the time to join
us